we can begin this hour with the legacy
of covert we're talking about both the
loss of life also the lockdowns and how
it could influence the midterm elections
and we focused in on the State of
Florida which on the one hand had the
12th highest death rate in the country
382 fatalities for every 100 000 people
according to the CDC that is more than
other big States like California and New
York but at the same time Governor Ron
DeSantis says he was right to reopen the
state's economy and remove restrictions
long before many of his more cautious
peers so now voters get to decide which
approach they want to reward the one in
Florida and also Beyond
oh
for a moment in early 2020 every
governor in America seemed to be saying
the same thing we don't want large
crowds of people congregating right now
practice physical distancing to fight a
deadly new virus we all needed to stay
home you should not congregate in crowds
but an effort to keep the public safe
also meant shutting down schools
and squeezing people's ability to make a
living
people like Eddie Morris owner of
Infamous Fitness Studio in Hialeah
Florida it was horrible because you're
counting in your bank account thinking
can I make this next payment or am I
going to close down what's going to
happen to my facility up in Florida as
frustration mounted Blue State Governors
State cautious committed to following
Federal guidance while Republicans like
Governor Ron DeSantis went on to defy it
people know that Florida is a free state
they're not going to have these shut
down they're not going to have
restrictions lifting stay at home orders
reopening schools for in-person learning
and dropping mask mandates sometimes
months before the CDC considered it wise
if you are trying to lock people down I
am standing in your way for Morris and
his wife Brittany that meant relief what
about if this gym were in New York oh
forget it I'd be done I'd be washed out
we'd be finished
and for Ron DeSantis it meant
reinvention as a national hero to some
and a national Target to others covered
at Santos is just acting irresponsibly
the highest hospitalization rate in the
State of Florida at any point in the
pandemic and yet DeSantis has been
fighting tooth and nail to stop any type
of mandate so more than two years later
a question who was right we were right
and they were wrong and millions of
families in Florida are better for it is
Ron DeSantis right no Dr David Aegis is
a CBS News medical contributor I can't
say one right one wrong and that's part
of the problem it's not a binary black
white issue one study tried to compare
all of it taking into consideration the
economy education and public health a
final report card written in part by
researchers from right-leaning
organizations did give Florida an a
while California and New York got
failing grades
but another study in the journal Nature
notes a problem weighing harms and
benefits often comes down not to
Scientific calculations but to Value
judgments Mass work in the right setting
shutdowns work in the right setting and
that being said in the wrong setting
they have very little role and so you
cannot be absolute about them does
Governor Ron DeSantis deserve credit
for any part of his coveted policy that
you've seen I think he did provide
leadership and you know I respect that
part of I give him credit for that I
think he caught a mood in Florida that
worked very much to his Advantage Dario
Moreno is a political science professor
at Florida International University
he says reopening in a state that
practically runs on tourism and the
service industry actually put DeSantis
in a stronger position today than when
he first campaigned on the coattails of
Donald Trump then Mr Trump said you're
fired he ran very much in the shadows of
trump and this has really created his
own image what is that image he stood up
for Freedom he stood up for opening up
which is exactly how DeSantis now
presents himself Florida will be the
Vanguard of freedom in this country
an image that ignores a lot of Heartache
according to his opponent Charlie Crist
over 6 million of my fellow Floridians
have gotten this pandemic and we don't
yet know the terms of you know long coat
you know so I no I don't think his
record on this is Sterling I don't think
it's admirable I think it's appalling
but what really matters to voters when
it comes to covid isn't facts and
figures says Moreno it's feelings this
is a deeply emotional issue
if you lost your job if you lost your
house if someone close to you died all
these things play into it so we're not
really voting on Covert we're voting on
our personal experience with cope and
for people like Eddie Morris his
experience points to just one conclusion
How likely from where you're sitting is
it that Governor DeSantis is going to
win re-election
for me it's hands down
yeah a lot of people are saying that it
seems hands down right now yeah I
recently she went to Florida and I
talked to maybe 50 voters in three
different parts of the state this is for
a piece that we haven't aired yet and I
found nothing but Ron DeSantis supporter
so in the State of Florida from a
political point of view his moves on
covid are very very popular and it comes
down to perception in your household do
you care more about the economic effects
or do you care more about the public
health effects if you care more about
the economy and you weren't affected
luckily by the other stuff then you love
what he did yeah I think the point about
feelings being more important than facts
and figures really resonates with a lot
of people yeah I I get that if you are
as he said somebody who lost somebody
close to themselves you have one way
that you think about it if you're
somebody who had it and nothing happened
to you then you have another feeling
about it yeah but see lockdowns and
shutdowns affect the whole state whereas
covet fatalities affect only those
households where they occur but but the
shutdowns also work too well so there's
debate about the extent to which there
was a benefit it and then this is where
you get into the value judgment and
there's not a clean answer you can't go
to science and say dear science what is
the answer and then you get one it's all
context and feeling yeah